welcome to this video this is round two
coverage of Tatas to 2015 and again
seven games and I'm going to well
Charlie I'll show them all but some are
some are more interesting than others
let's say so let's start right off the
bat and go with the world champion
magnus carlsen with his first white game
playing wesley so from the US yeah
Townsend opens up with c4 quite not a
big surprise but not what he usually
does he can play any opening basically
but he's mostly playing efore recently
also in his match against are not see
form not so much but of course he has
done this before so it's not a sensation
or anything I was slightly surprised
that in in this particular move all
cards now didn't take the option to stay
within the English opening and play e49
f3 but he actually took this chance to
transpose to the yeah we can almost say
transpose to the NIMS oh because that's
what everybody plays him on the top
level yeah of course Wesley so is also
playing the names of here and we get a
Rubinstein with e3 and 92 this is one of
the lines that um yeah this line has
gotten recent coverage in a couple of
books actually many repertoire books for
wide recommend the line and I think it's
mostly due to the fact that where the
other lines are simply very very complex
and this is relatively easy to present
it's not like this is giving wide that
much what wants to avoid the double porn
and he's successful in that but in the
way by doing that he also haven't
persist development and we will see that
after d5 and III like drop back here you
can debate bishop d6 is also move of
course takes takes no g3 was played yeah
it's a it's a debate here theoretically
bait what white should do you know
to play night f form ya like like this
is possible or can go here even stuff
like this is possible there are many
moves but they all share one
characteristics they don't lead to avoid
advantage what you have is however a
pretty complex position or pieces on the
board so kind of the thing that guards
and likes it's not a forced force term
Battle of preparation but just the game
and well they played a couple of fairly
I think normal-looking moves and well a
4 was a bit surprising I mean trying to
maybe attack the night but a 5 stopped
it and you know one issue that I have
with this position is I'm not totally
sure what White's big plan is now I mean
if you look at this a 3 and B 3 this a 4
and b3 this is basically frozen the
queenside it's very difficult for y to
get anything on the queenside going in
fact yeah there's nothing happening
there the only thing that white has left
in this position it's something like
f380 for ye for breaking in the center
which is not a surprise why it has an
extra pawn there but you'll be difficult
to realize and black has a very
straightforward plan he regroups his
night young and to be four and takes a
while and all looks very very normal but
now it starts the regrouping yeah note
that white had a bad bishop on be two
cards pneus exchanging that that's all
very good and natural and now the night
is coming over to a 6 looking at this
weekend square yeah and we see that well
black has no bad piece and the only
thing that really has to check as well
is he going to play you for or not and
if black can make a fee for ya of caneva
if he can really show that this isn't a
big thing to happen then black is
completely fine in this game is exactly
that what happened Carlson actually
managed to play
after a while to play you for him but
this is mostly a leading to mess
exchanges and we can check that this is
what happened Wesley so could just trade
everything off and now he centralized
the Queen and well here you can actually
debate whether maybe black get something
up probably i'm really not but it's it's
clear that white is absolutely nothing
here dropped back with the rook they
actually made a draw relatively quickly
i think and somewhere here they they
have licked in this repetition yeah
there is not not much happening really
White has a somewhat weak pawn on d4
black one on c6 and it's difficult to
avoid the repetition like him okay black
could have taken you on d1 rook takes
but I mean are you playing for winners
black probably not so this is a pretty
much uneventful game um yeah I don't
know I mean to be perfectly honest I
don't like this line very much for white
I think it's very it's a bit I know
unambitious may be wrong but I always
feel like like has no problems
whatsoever you have a healthy
development clean and white only has the
c-4 idea I don't know it's not I'm not
not a huge fan of this line but it it
really turned out that cars also
couldn't couldn't do much with it the
next game i'm going to show you really
briefly it's Aronian with white against
onigiri why briefly yeah this is one of
those cases where you look at the game
and you at first think wait this is kind
of exciting what are they doing and then
you check afterwards or read some
article on the game or some some piece
of news that it was all seen before and
shaken because they played a gruen fault
with queen bee 3d replays with 96 it's
an interesting sideline that black can
go for main lines are a six and probably
9 a-6 as played by cars in the world
championship match and this this is an
interesting move it leads to technical
play it looks interesting at first but
why black is sacrificing upon now we'll
see six he's introducing the idea to
play night XD Phi of a tactic Quincy
fought to keep it and now yet another
pawn sacrifice so this looks really kind
of Wow nice what they're doing here well
it's all well known it seems that there
have been games with it and it's funny
enough there's a game a recent game have
to check this actually in my notes I
forgot to the white player was a job off
the job of white against our own young
black so with reverse colors all this
has been played in Beijing just a couple
of weeks ago so they were basically
rapid this game and around yet on the
other side funny enough and note that if
you look at look at the clock times that
aronian is is playing quickly and geary
as well so they both were totally aware
what's going on now by now black has
been secretary pawns but he gets this
back it all looks spectacular but they
just reproduce in what they know and
should take 75 Queen here castles we're
still this is all charted waters Queen
d6 and now here in the original game
aronian being black he played the move
Bishop to e6 yeah Black is two pawns
down and the only thing that black is
playing for with this all this stuff is
a draw actually yeah you want to
simplify get a pawn back maybe and then
draw the endgame upon down which is kind
of unattractive but what was what give
you was after here it seems Bishop a
dream and write a form
here going straight in I'm e27 Queen
f/4g three Queen f6 believe it a lot
this is the new move the first new move
on move 23 Queen takes e4 was played in
a in an earlier game by two not so well
known players like 2200 players Queen f6
yeah what does it lead to an end game
upon down black gets this be porn but we
see opposite colored bishops so there is
some I mean black definitely has chances
to draw very intact chances to draw the
kind of so don't really know why why you
would you play this kind of line is
black you actually even have to suffer a
bit and I don't know at the end I really
really didn't really feel like I should
put a huge effort into finding out if
what could he could have gone for more
black always has I mean very active play
and he got he got one porn back him yeah
you can ask why is why play king edge
one it's it's very difficult to make any
headway you always tied him a note
erroneous still has tons of time on his
clock simply because he could play very
quickly audion and this was played white
activated his rook alright it's probably
a draw all the way but check the only
slightly interesting situation comes at
the end Jack not really interesting what
this was the final move rook g1 check
King g1 and King g3 and then I just
wanted to briefly mention because
there's some a growing amount of people
who think that computers will show you
the correct evaluation all of the time
this is very often the case that they
give you the correct evaluation but if
you look at this look at this position
up here with the computer that does not
have a table base it's very important of
course if they have a table base they
will play it perfectly and show that
this position is
raw but if you give it to any normal
engine I can take whatever you want
stock Fisher Komodo or whatever Houdini
it will say White's winning and this is
total nonsense sh5 something like this
shows tragic kingi cell and black is
putting the king on h8 and just draws
very comfortable area with you the wrong
corner wait sorry the wrong wrong color
this yeah you can actually take the pawn
I'm sorry this was kind of kind of quick
why should at least try to hold the pawn
but it is of course it is silly
reception and now Blackie is sitting
nicely in the corner he would always
sacrifice this Bishop for the a pawn to
make the draw pretty simple and
straightforward so every engine with our
table base has white is winning okay not
a very exciting game maybe I'm doing it
a little bit of injustice but I really
feel no point in checking at this
completely artificial game from the
computer is is that that interesting
okay let's look at the next game zubaba
vashi lagrave Jabara the the the guy who
lost this very unfortunate king at porn
end game against iran ship when he
offered the rook trade in round one very
unfortunate start for him let's see what
he did today plate 92 year against the
sicilian yeah this is a funny little
move it's actually leading to a
transposition to to the open society
often when white plays d for next maybe
it's just designed to gain a like half a
minute on the clock yeah knight c6 93 g6
yeah this is an option that Black now
has he can enter this this opening the
accelerators dragon without allowing the
maroc see bind as white has played
93 what I'm talking about is if we look
at this there is this opening the
accelerated dragon and here the main
reason why people are not playing that
so much is black is the maracas see bind
with c4 wear black frankly is not
equalizing ever white is just always
little little bit better black hands
chances to to make it bearable of course
it's not a terribly bad opening but it
feels some it puts off people from this
opening the accelerated dragon have me
included actually I would I wouldn't
mind to play play this is black but
we'll see for now not so much and in
this game here we see that with g6 here
what basically well if he wants to do
anything he has to go d 4 + and so to
bother did now we get the accelerated to
dragon and yeah but without c4 plate so
the normal accelerated dragon not the
more oxy point and do bother however now
I'm goes for something interesting it
feels that he was somewhat surprised
maybe which is a bit which is not clear
why because of a Sheila graph had played
this before but okay it seems that he
did not really have anything great up
his sleeve here and he played Bishop to
e2 and which is not a bad setup in
general I'm sorry the bishop each was
liens against almost any Sicilian are
pretty pretty solid the only thing that
really surprises is that here he
actually castled and I would have
expected him to play maybe night to be
three to take some control over the d5
square yeah if Black gets in d5 in one
move and this is what happened castles
d5 he usually equalizes without any
effort and this is what happened here
why should a graph obviously playing him
he's not playing for a draw that's wrong
and I didn't even wanted to form that
sentence
he plays that will theoretically
recommended moose and it is the best
move because it equalizes very
comfortably but it also moves that
basically says okay yeah well I'm fine
with the draw because what can do the
following this year I'm Bishop c4 a
bishop f3 sorry Quincy for cakes takes
c3 and this is the kind of position
where white really really has to do
something stupid to lose it's just that
those bishops are very nicely anchored
this is a slight weakness and black
already black is active enough with his
bishops I mean this bishops only 62 to
keep it equal but there's absolutely
very little chance of something exciting
happening yeah we see that this was
traded yeah the c6 pawn was immediately
traded and well here this is just really
nothing happening they sort of invented
a repetition here and interrupt up the
game so very unexcited a possibility is
that Jabbar was simply was too disgusted
with herself of her after the first
round where he blundered away this an
end game against you want you maybe you
just wanted to to to have a day off
let's say and and it's but sometimes
sometimes it's not a bad idea if you
feel like okay well I totally screwed up
the round before that let's just yeah
get get a fresh mind on the following
day and not play a game today that costs
any any sort of energy so probably not
such a bad idea okay the next one is the
job of even shook a job of played a
relatively uneventful draw and round one
and Yvonne ships game there wasn't that
much happening to be honest against new
barber but then jus bhava basically hit
the self-destruction button and and lost
this forever transpose into the king
important game yeah this game actually
it was a really long game
but there was never something super
exciting happening the only thing that I
would like to point out which is not
much I admit it is that they played this
opening here an idea 3g 3 which I play
quite a lot this kind of lines 93 g3 and
avant sugars playing now the move B 5
which might look funny to some people
because well the early be part pushes
especially if they had two squares
sometimes frowned upon a little bit like
let's say the the moves one B form the
so-called ski opening or and now I'm not
pronouncing that right the rang a tang
rang a tang it's close it's not that bad
pronunciation and well this kind of
thing that this is simply not a grain
move but the this case here is a little
bit different b5 you actually i'll move
to is a very very decent line and the
reason is because what has already
basically committed to a fianchetto the
move b5 often is tricky or before and
they're in there in the initial position
because annie pawn move will attack this
pawn like well this is ridiculous now
but this kind of move it would attack
the pawn but with g3 already being
played the move b5 gains a little in
strength because well the bishop will
fianchetto and this means that this is
not so much of a weakness and well what
is b5 doing well it controls c4 that's
an important almost central square yeah
my definition the center those those fun
but c4 is a very important square
because you would like very often white
would like to put a pawn on c4 and this
is not easy now with the B pawn on d5
this is actually a really good line
against 9003 g3 if you happen to play
Knight f6 and
you want to have something that is kind
of middle of the road it's not totally
boring there is some play in there and
on the other hand you don't want to do
something crazy so it's a very good
approach for a game to just play in fact
I think that if one should come yeah I
am very not fairly normally here you can
also argue the g6 is certainly okay but
you can also argue black can also play
esox e6 or c5 those kind of moves they
are also fine this again we are
approaching a very symmetrical position
but like it's losing a little bit of
time there yeah this actually I thought
that white should maybe have a little
something but it's turned out to be not
that substantial and little something
because of the time loss yeah like here
here here and on the seven it's also not
that great but it seems that the
position is very funny yeah just like it
was back to get this night developed
yeah and even chuck was pick this
relatively quickly that's funny and raja
baath spent spent ages didn't know the
clock times when i looked at the games
yeah it actually they traded some stuff
and here well why it is a little bit
better due to the space but it's nothing
super serious and um i don't think that
something super exciting happened in
this game they traded and I mean it's
probably always equal ish chat this is
at least whatever I gathered from the
the round reports and I didn't look at
it in such detail because it didn't look
very exciting a check here black
actually this was funny but what did
happen here chef to it's a funny move
yeah like actually got to this end game
a porn up but
it is a draw there with the White King
being that active back they probably can
yeah white got all the pawns yeah I
probably do this a little bit too
quickly to really get something out of
it but I don't think it was a very very
exciting game you probably won't feel
very enlightened if I spent an hour on
it to be perfectly honest let's see what
else we have van really voy de check
let's look at this game this was in fact
more interesting can tell you that much
what I also can tell you is I don't find
my notes here there are ok and when
really also playing Knight f3 g3 yeah I
always thought that those openings are a
little bit underestimated I play them
for a while now and not underestimated
in a theoretical sense they mostly lead
to positions that are that i equal ish
but what this the setups often do they
keep many pieces on the board so if you
feel you want a long game and try to
outplay the opponent in an along in a
long better it's not a bad idea it's a
it's noteworthy then in some cases in
chess history those kind of slower
setups were chosen when the wind was
needed them the most famous example is
the world championship match 1987 in
seville where I'm Kasparov needed to win
in round in the twenty fourth and final
game and he chose the reti opening not
this move water but it it leads to
something similar okay well here what a
shake is playing something that I think
is quite good you just place like it ism
is a reversed opening it just tries to
take the center and this is an important
moment white now absolutely has to play
deform like the Guru Infeld reverse if
he's not doing that something like
castles light same black will play a
five for the Kings Indian reversed our
Kings Indian attack in this case and the
Kings Indian attack with white against
this broad center is
absolutely nothing just equal if you are
lucky as wide let's say the extra tempo
is not really helping in any way so if
you want something you rather play the
greenford reversed and the best line is
now actually what water shake played
black is simply developing here like
that and now we funny enough have
transposed into a kettle and opening
yeah this is normally arising from a
catalan move water and here why it has a
wide choice of sharp moves are white so
it's a bit much you can play Knight a
395 those kind of moves 95 actually is a
funny little trap I mean okay on that
level and no problem but some people
tend to still take end after e3 they
yeah make one of those very embarrassed
faces here after the night moves you're
going to back check lose a big group
here the corner yeah well queen a force
play I'm just a little bit more than
conventional way to do it black is
gaining some space but why does some
getting a pretty good center um I didn't
look up this line in in a book I mean
it's maybe in one of the average books
but I didn't have the time to check it
the only thing that I know is that I
really like in vain is opening position
look this kind of thing this isn't this
a good position for white you have a
good center blacks structure is a little
bit a little bit harmed already I mean
it's not like a terrible structure but
long-term the King might might be might
be a problem and white as mansion has a
nice enter a d5 pushes and so on I like
the whites position in the opening even
if the computer is not seeing anything I
still thought that why this is pretty
okay um it is actually later that that's
something something interesting happens
and we'll go on a little bit the real
problem really long term is always that
white has that's a better King position
with his castling Bishop on g2 is really
safe well it's not so clear where the
black king goes it's always tricky to
play when you don't have a clear clear
save King position and the game here
ultimately opened up see ya night coming
back into the game no we've got a couple
of trades yeah and simply note this King
yeah if if let's say the porn would be
here on g7 it simply nothing is going on
equal material White has a deep on black
has a beep on now you can argue maybe
someone is slightly better worse but
it's really not much going on in here it
might still be okay the computer just
claims equality but this is not a very
comfortable position to play for like I
always have to be lowered that you're
not allowing something on the king and
in fact a couple of moves later and
black actually made a mistake we are
going to see that f 6m alright this is
not a good square yeah as white already
tries to prove kingi cell h5 clear
intentions but black can't cover it q j7
was probably not the best move by the
way we go back here black probably had
to do something else and there's not
that much that he can do probably f5
here to block the Queen g6 check yeah
but again this is a loose King as an
open King I don't think that this is
very comfortable but he had to do that
well King g7 was played not that water
shake it much more time on the clock
than when very aged five be sure to
eight covering g6 look a one yeah
angling
for a quick entry of this rook route 8
Bishop h3 activating the bishop that's a
good move and now black went green to be
6 Queenie 7 was better why does some
enjoying an advantage simply based on
this bad King and the possibility is
related to the deep on but now Queen B 6
was played this is in fact losing its a
that's quite funny we will see Bishop e6
is a strong just yeah getting this
position right into this Bishop right
into the heart of blacks position and
now it will be very very tricky to
defend the bishop is participating in
the attack black now played Bishop h5
there is it's really the thing that wide
the move that wide as threatening is
absolutely impossible to prevent but
from really didn't play it but now I
understand better why he didn't play it
he didn't have much time on the clock I
was just looking at the game without
knowing what the time a situation was
and him this is maybe an interesting
situation for you to find a tactic if
you want to share for a little bit of
time pause the video try to find a
tactic now why to play and win
yeah why do plan will and he wins with
the rookie six that's a nice move rook
sacrifice if black takes it then white
enters check Queen c7 check kingi six
men and now just green takes and it was
this position that has to be had to be
correctly assessed you quickly see that
white definitely has an attack of course
with retina Queen g8 mate yeah that's a
completed it's a full mate and the thing
is black it really has no defense but it
had to be assessed correctly beforehand
and well then really didn't have much
time on the clock it finishes like that
by the way tragic and now Bishop f7
that's a big point black hand jack give
this check and keep this Bishop for the
moment but wyd simply has d 6 and this
poem porn is some yeah this bone is
promoting and after any move why does
Chad doing this and we promote yeah luca
essex a move that then very definitely
is capable of finding but if you just
have 40-something seconds it's a tricky
move to play especially if you if we go
back to the position here after you went
here especially when you see that even
without any fancy sacrifices you
definitely will have a good position wyd
still is some right still ism and for
choice iam Roxy one yeah probably
intended Queen c7 but it's just far less
forcing than what he could have had
other ideas of course maybe to get the
Queen here or here and then look to c 6
now those kind of those kind of ideas
white has little tremendous compensation
for the pawn bishop to e8 uniform age
five and Queen B for you're intending to
invade here on his heaven
and queen d6 Queen a5 king of eight back
yeah Black is still on the ropes King g6
was was a better defense Queen a7
push-up d7 and now again a nice move
yeah probably you can find it why does a
strong move now in Roxy 6 yeah not
difficult actually if black takes oops
at me we've got a mate coming so black
has to move the Queen and of course he
did now rook see Sapna is a fantastic
fantastic position white is dominating
completely black has to play king yet
not too too loose material instantly but
yeah it's in vain why it is just much
much better and there were many ways
actually too now in the next couple of
moves well you win a little bit quicker
but what when really did was always
keeping a huge advantage you know he won
the beep on black couldn't really do
anything is basically forced to play
those those moves that he that he had
can get one also got taken check yeah
and it's a queen ant game with an extra
pot important point is that blacks pawns
are also week so white has excellent
winning chances in this in this end game
Queen geforce plate and now f3 yeah very
important is that this is not a good
idea oh wait let me think about this
when I looked at it before and I was
thinking that this should be a draw as
blackest is approaching the pawn but if
we check it like here Kingda seven I
have this right this is a win right this
is the win why didn't he take the Queen
on g4 that's kind of curious check this
is just the wind right and why this
clearly winning why didn't he trade the
Queen interesting he didn't have much
time so maybe one minute something maybe
he got irritated yeah I mean the thing
is even even after what he played his
winning it's not like it wasn't like
this is also winning when various move
now but not this one this was the
problem he should play F for him Queen
moves 96 and white is winning this end
came very comfortably do to those both
porns being weak white will win one of
the pawns but the kid poor endgame was a
really simple draw a simple win quite
weird but okay one minute on the clock
hmm that's tricky already it's also a
bit of a nerve problem simply that you
have to be well this little time you
have to keep your keep your yeah you
your mental stability that you don't
kind of get irritated by things and so
on it's very important and maybe what he
am his somewhat miss miscounted
something on something like that the
thing is he went here and now this is
all of a sudden and very tricky and I
think actually probably a draw black
entering them is a huge a huge issue
they continued for quite a long while
but it seems that black now and has this
counter play ideas
check check yeah tons of chicks check
and wide returned one point because he
saw that you can't got h5 but check this
is not a winner anymore shayan fact it
is often if it's a very good piece of
advice maybe that I can give to you in
in end games with them in queen end
games you really really have to be be
cautious because even because of the big
power of the Queen you can easily do
very stupid things and actually lose
being upon upon up I mean this is not an
in check this was played let me just do
one thing I know it doesn't make much
sense probably but i just want to show
you something yeah let's say a position
like that yeah black is threatening
checkmate here yeah and this is just one
one moment of yeah not being alert and
and you can you can actually lose them
here's them here it's a draw or if you
feel if you want something like this can
also happen yeah check this is a check
actually okay i was i was getting at
line like this chang where widest
blundering yeah you know it's the queens
are very very tricky and so must have to
be cautious all of the time check in the
game then they made a couple of more
checks and actually agree to a draw here
yeah this is this is a drawn endgame
yeah like always it has to be ready for
the opposition you know this distant
opposition or this this is the
the nia opposition that the classic form
of it yeah really not not really great
here certainly how when Vinny must feel
after the game he had excellent winning
chance and could have one on numerous
occasions the easiest probably the king
and porn and care transformation but as
I mentioned yesterday we saw in the game
by ljubavi against Iran shook you have
to think about those things if you're
going to go to a king and porn and game
and he didn't have much time so he was
probably not totally sure and then
selected to stay or just to keep this is
this gradient game which would have one
actually but it wasn't it wasn't that
easy it seems okay the next game is um
where is it my notes are completely
untidy this is who you found with wide
the women were champion against ding
Liren his her country what is the right
name that I country mate this is the
word yeah they're both from China let's
get to this game where are we here here
are we done we found with wide against
ding Liren let's see what happened we
got a calc on which ding is playing
quite often I looked it up i didn't know
it and we got a ton of a check that's
one of them let's say less fashionable
ways to play against the CARICOM
nowadays everybody plays some the
advanced variation advanced variation
and to be perfectly honest I think any
is probably any real serious player
let's say master level and above should
play the advanced it seems to be the the
most testing variation simply but for
for developing players I often recommend
the part of a tech this kind of line it
leads to open piece play and very it's
very
very technical variation in a way
because of those pieces all out EMC
bishops open and so on you will have
technical games quite often yeah of
course we find she started developing
player she's what she will improve
definitely it's but it's not like we
start talking about some junior player
but she's playing the part of simply
because it's an interesting line maybe
as a surprise weapon and I think and
probably she had exactly this line in
mind that she played now and did not
play Bishop to e6 this is them yeah
there are there us more than one
frequently played line this is one of
the better known ones yeah here who you
fancy played a an interesting sideline
that however is probably not that great
objectively speaking maybe she wanted to
as mentioned surprise I'm ding and play
something less well lesson doesn't known
she played Nagi to e2 it looks really a
bit strange to smooth but the idea is to
play Knight to f4 and try to expose that
this Bishop is actually on a funny
square yeah I should probably tell
something about this Bishop move isn't
this strange-looking it is but there was
some pressure on the d5 pawn and black
is arguing that he doesn't want to play
ecigs which is not terrible but he does
not want to block the bishop and well
you cannot be play something like that
this is just blundering upon so this is
actually if you want the preparation for
a later fianchetto and white really has
to do something here also about the idea
to sometimes just take on c4 in the
correct circumstance of course um yeah
92 is an interesting move it seems that
Bishop e2 and a 3 are currently regarded
as most dangerous a 3 looks weird but
it anticipates move like Queen a five to
be answered with before um probably
those moves are also better i think that
92 is really nothing much i am actually
have played this myself and with white
um when i played before on a rare
occasion i had prepared this line but i
made some mistakes in the preparation
and and i rechecked it actually today
and let it was really nothing for what a
bit mystified what the idea was to be
honest because well this is pretty
pretty straightforward but this is
somehow how it went at Bishop c4 as one
of the points of this this line the idea
is that this year is not that convincing
I black and play it but it's it's not
that great Queen a 497 long castles it's
the funny tactical point now intending
rook t7 this is actually how my game
went when i played this against german
feeder master in 2002 Queen takes but
should be fired funny line right Jack's
really really funny I damn it seems that
black is some yeah this is what happened
in my game he actually found this over
the board which was a pretty good
achievement and f4 and so on seems to be
a draw ultimately I mean really I don't
want to get into this but it is
something where black is sort of walking
a tightrope and maybe he holds it but
it's it's tricky I actually lost the
game with what i blundered a couple of
moves later and the thing is that well
you don't have to do to do this you
don't have to take you can also just
trade here and play a six which is
exactly what ding Liren what he did and
now it's kind of curious what should why
do white has sacrificed
gone and what she did now is really
leading to absolutely nothing when she
took on his sixth giving up the bishop
Pam and continuing that maybe hoping
that the extra pawn I mean this is
probably not a totally wrong assumption
that the extra point is not dead useful
but it's definitely absolutely nothing
for white ya mean white has no chances
whatsoever to win and we see that like
it's activating him step by step yeah it
takes a while because you have this kind
of yeah this is not a very nicely
coordinate position at the moment and
this is probably where who you found
where she saw her chance is maybe trying
to use this this coordination problems
but I think ding is playing this
excellent red b6 now that's a good move
yeah night a six the first thing your
thing off but look at this this this
piece has no squares b6 covered c7 has
covered be a discovered and you don't
want to do that yeah after Bishop g7
Blackwell get display coordinate it may
be night coming here all night coming to
d5 that's actually one problem this
double porn is giving black some nice
points for operations in the center yeah
well she didn't take she went to d 397
and maybe here this this and I really
don't like the next move I'm not sure
how good other moves are but i'm pretty
sure that after what she played she went
95 check but after that what is really
really struggling to draw the computer
is also viewing it them in that way the
reason why i think jesus if you look at
this now one problem is that it's at
long term this is all on light squares
here and this is a good structure for
this bishop this dark squared bishop on
the other hand white has the the
tendency it's not like
pawns are there but many pawns those two
own dark squares so there is the
potential here for a bad Bishop endgame
and in fact this is what ultimately
happened black activated he gave a pawn
back and this is just a very very
comfortable endgame for black he's got
the better pawn structure in relation to
the bishop the good good structure d 5
is a week palm and black has ideas
sometimes to invade with the king is
just a little bit more active with the
king black has excellent winning chances
here and he actually went on to win this
fairly comfortably I didn't look at this
in much detail to be honest it looked
very very close to losing to me anyway
and maybe there is some great defensive
idea but I doubt it i think black is
probably really winning with the some
precision has got a pawn and the more
active position check now we got down to
a rook endgame check where c5 is falling
and now the decisive factor is the beep
on which is supported by the king the
black rook is cutting back Dwight King
often Josh I I can change it for a
little more yeah and here um she
resigned like it's just moving the King
to one of those and then we'll promote
yeah it came well it is a little bit
tricky to understand the rationale
behind the opening selection because
well it seems to be still the state of
theory but well I played it myself back
then because back then it was believed
that here white maybe has a little
something but after a six sisters not
seem to be the case why definitely has
some compensation maybe maybe she
shouldn't take on his six I don't know
this this is really
that's a very a friend of mine sometimes
as vegetarian move it's not really
showing that you are bloodthirsty okay
well the second loss for the women world
champion very bad start to this
tournament with two losses of course
she's some not the favorite in this
event but she played it in I think 2013
and really did a good job so I'm still
expecting her to to score a couple of
points okay and the final game that we
look at is kiwana tobiano karana with
white the word number two playing yvonne
and i'm trying this shara shara CH
someone said i should pronounce it like
that or at least let me try to pronounce
it like that sure rich ok um II for by
faviana as usual he's doing this pretty
reliably nowadays and we got a close to
elope s not the Berlin thankfully and as
it happens the other lines are more
interesting then the Berlin at least for
the spectator um this is in fact the the
site's f variation characterized by rook
e8 and Bishop e7 this can also be played
in switched move order Bishop e7 and
rook e8 first this was actually the
choice of Anatoly Karpov in his world
championship matches against Garry
Kasparov the line really am I still
think is pretty ok for black um but at
the time was I said that cup of lost a
ton of games with it and i'm pretty sure
that when he saw that chronic was
basically a yeah completely diffusing
kasparov's whiter whiter whites serve in
his London match I think that cap off
really really must have thought oh wow
why did I come up with the idea to play
the berlin wall i guess if cup of would
have had this idea would have regained
the title at some
this matches against Kasparov he always
scored excellently with wide against
Gaspar off but he lost a ton of black
games and the ROI okay well let's see
what happens special Elaine the idea of
black set up by the way this quick
rookie aid Bishop f8 Bishop e7 their
ideas actually that there is a somewhat
there are serious pressure on the e4
pawn which is some which is very clearly
demonstrated by the fact that the
standard we regrouping night f1 is
actually a mistake as black can take and
the e4 pawn is under under fire yeah so
white cannot do that and here he is at a
crossroads the most well the most played
move probably is the move a 4 which is
what Kasparov played most of the time
against cap off they I think it went h6
mostly but i'm not i'm not completely
sure it's been a while since i looked at
this there's also a 3 and all kinds of
moves the move that corona is playing is
a also very reliable on d5 this does not
look very logical yeah at first putting
the pawn on d5 when there is this bishop
on this diagonal the ideas however that
if we look at it like place might be
eight can also go to your seven and the
idea is that this bishop at the moment
is not doing that much but white will
get some play against this pawn on d5
yeah with c4 a four and so on quite
often black to make some sense of this
bishop on b7 me to make some sense of
this bishop will place his six and then
the bishop stang know will open up again
so it's not really a move that kills the
bishop it just turns the transom forms
the position in a way that it probably
will become useful later night f1 night
bd7 my 32 H to this looks kind of
curious but
the idea is that if black place is six
which is normal actually in this
position or let's say it is normal to
play it quite often in this kind of form
when this is inserted that in this
structure the knight on f6 will play
useful role in controlling d5 and night
h2s play too often trade it with larger
form however genre chair played a
different we didn't play 95 which is by
far the main move you played the move f5
however this was something that could
could have been anticipated by Caruana
as cirrage had played it before I found
a game in the database um well karana
obviously didn't expect it he played a
for him spending 20 minutes and I think
isn't this good that they sometimes
actually play some chess over the board
very good okay a form might make sense
yeah you want to attack this week
queenside black pushed with before and
now we got to this and at first I was
thinking wait is this good for what
before looks like a somewhat weak porn
and this is probably true but it's not
so easy to use as we see that in the
game black has gotten some activity with
the night putting some pressure there
it's not so easy now for why to do
something against the point if you play
something like that well a foursome
attacked and black can also always play
c6 and getting play against the center
yeah if we look at this for example not
the bishop what f6 now comes into play
yeah it is an interesting position here
maybe white has a little something but
it's not not yeah nothing decisive by
any means you know this is Queen side is
still a little bit shaky but I think
Zara to stop doing anything wrong here
look
sharukh I'm sorry yeah we have got two
bishops against two nights funny
situation but still from a structural
point of view why does certainly quite
nice yet before is a week porn but it's
nothing it's nothing yet very very
dramatic okay interesting now with f5
black is playing this in a very sharp
manner and he pleaded really quickly I'm
not sure about this this guy I have seen
some games of Shah Rukh and really think
good player but i don't really know
about its time management maybe he's
playing quickly all the time but you
really played this this this kind of
stuff here to play this in 22 minutes
that's strong strong statement and
because it's the kind of move that you
don't come back from you know it's just
like very very m committal well okay it
seems to be so okay Black now has
sacrifice upon but he's gotten this this
nice central pawns active pawns 93 and
now exactly now we get to the critical
position of the game there's just one
critical position of this cave and this
is exactly here um now um the black
player went Queen B seven and he took
some time for it five minutes and it
really seems to be that this is the only
serious mistake that he made in the game
and it's probably yeah costing him the
whole game it looks very it looks very
unsuspicious smooth not very not nothing
exciting but the problem is the
following white plays this move 93 you
are getting this night back into play
and this is now a big problem this is
hanging and there's this threat Knights
e5 e6 and both threats combined
exceptionally difficult to to defend
against an additional problem is the
following he went rookie aid which it
first looks quite good if
consider this is possible but not that
decisive maybe this is the problem
playback caruana caranas playing this
game again without any any serious
mistake or inaccuracies really really
good Quincy for attacking the bishop and
he decided not to take only 3 which is
nothing that you love to do but have a
look at this if you keep the keep this
is this coming and also be for hangs I
mean this is also something to consider
after you for it's not that clear maybe
something like this White has those
strong pawns but it's probably the other
line is probably even more convincing
yeah he took only three and now a move
that surprised me but it's strong he
took with the pawn looks a bit strange
to block the own work but taking where
the pawn is strong after that before
it's not that clear while after context
Bishop d7 was played but it's black now
place before we see 11 nice difference
why can jump here like well somewhere
what do I have in my notes Queen Bee a
there's probably not much very much then
white jump cm and goes back to d4 and
now we see how nice it is to have the
pawn there this position is really flat
out winning yet what a fantastic knight
on d4 it is safely protected by the e3
pawn it protects f5 it protects b3 and
well it's just in the middle of the
board like a rock fantastic so this this
was really for was not even trying to
find Carol to play so he didn't do that
he played Bishop 27 Queen before this
one was falling Queen 8 next move is
somewhat remarkable I think because well
if you look at this white is two pawns
up and probably will win with many many
moves and
the karana is playing the absolute best
one here as it turns out by when you
check it with the computer is the best
one he played g-form I would be
reluctant to play that that move to be
perfectly honest to open up my king like
that it is really the case that there's
nothing happening with the King White
has pieces around it it's it's fairly
safe but still need to be very confident
about your your assessment of the
situation to play the move g-form there
is really nothing happening White has
everything under perfect control so he
made the right the right judgment so it
shows that he's really really confident
yeah here black black is completely
busted i can counted three bonds and
black has absolutely no idea what to do
here to get Kevin to play eva is also
falling he tried this can of desperado
him and he resigned the game so we have
a win here for Caruana winning his
second game in round two so two out of
two good start for him we would see if
he can repeat his head performance of
the same fluid cup where he won seven
games in a row which is pretty much
impossible if he's doing that hmm I
don't know seven wins this is not on I
don't think that I think it was possible
okay I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
this round I actually wanted to make it
quicker and I feel like I rushed through
a rushed through some of the games it
still got two in one hour video I hope
you enjoyed it I'm back tomorrow I guess
with round three thanks for watching